è la tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj e oggi siamo sue
ragazze ogni volta che di questa frase
mi sembrano passati secoli ma anche
perché l'ultima volta
se non mi si fosse cancellata la
registrazione avreste visto il video
invece no papà ma chi se ne frega
superman verso sar comportiamo così chi
se ne frega ma vai con andy cos'è sta
roba presto z anche senza casco vai così
perché i veri superman non usano il
cazzo ma usano il paraculo che in questo
caso farebbero comodo ai club challenge
minchia si livelli mi stanno ispirando
ragazzi siamo all'inizio ma vi giuro che
stavolta vi ispirano il casinò vai così
il primo è che va vengono ciak e scarso
lo sappiamo anche di via con lavandaia
allora gli occhi a questo ci devi
pensare fuorché è bravo bambino madonna
ave ragazzi ho deciso di portare il mio
fratello a fare un giro in bici perché
era da secoli come non detto a the
attenta tanto mi scusi non volevo alla
bce andata da sola
[Musica]
che posizione di yoga mela i segni
madonna che potè cosa sto facendo io
cosa ragazzi che cazzo cosa stai facendo
che è un esorcismo ti stai avvicinando
pericolo a questo è il mio culo tocca lo
brutto stronzo ragazzi si sta incrinando
e come il titanic
ai donna che cosa vuol fare con
quell'arma mi cambiava la che non è un
giocattolo alessio mi avvicino e con il
mio fascino seducente cadrai ai miei
piedi
perfetto il giorno va beh meglio di
quanto pensassi bene che cosa ci faccio
le donne ragazze ok solo vivo servivo ok
mi hanno mi hanno appena sparato in
faccia ma sonno vi non facciamoci
domanda e vai col rock swing che da un
casino di tempo non ne faccio uno
decente hai e ti puoi vedere che c'è
ancora ci sei parà mi chiamino di un
nome non si ricorda neanche ma chi cazzo
brano fatto
la voglio nella nei libri di storia sta
cosa ed è fanta come cazzo ha fatta
cadere è di ce la puoi ancora fare fila
tv su ragazzi ancora non ho capito come
cazzo sia possibile che cosa devo fare
qui devo andare devo andare nel cannone
è bello fantastico ma è diva la vittoria
lo ringrazio di voi sballare dove che mi
spara non ho capito cosa ci faccio di là
la vittoria dalla parte opposta ragazzi
ancora perfetto va bene va bene lo
stesso basta che abbiamo vinto ma non
secolo non faccio un bel corona ma è
così vai a dire vai e ti che oggi vi dà
soddisfazioni
madonna va beh dai meno beviti due birre
neanche quella almeno ora i ragazzi
metti ma secoli che non faccio un voto
run fatemelo fare lo stesso hai così vai
così anch'io più o meno la mattina mi
sveglio così wrecking ball un altro ma
che cazzo quanti ce ne sono visti cosi
devo fare c'è proprio miley cyrus che mi
ha anche spezzato a metà a chi ve l'ha
è mista sodomizzando ciao miley o prova
immaginare amica mia con che cosa sono
attaccato alla palla da demolizione va
bene facciamo finta di nulla luke non
guardare non guardare questi atti osceni
no che fa uk molla anch'io voglio
attaccarmi ragazzi è una situazione
alquanto bizzarra questa ma facciamo
finta di nulla
voi non avete visto niente iscritte
borse da se vai così va mio dio e da
secoli che non ne faccio uno facciamolo
con babbo natale non ai dati come possa
fare sono attaccato sono attaccato per
il collo perfetto vinto forza e coraggio
amico mio forza e coraggio bene minchia
che testa dura acciaio
non ho fottutamente parole per
descrivere l'epicità di sto tizio rent
extreme cos'è stato non ci credo non ci
credo o tremila chilometri orari di
velocità va york fai vedere chi sei
un santo allucinante ok ma potenza
madonna di jack e potenza regalo siamo
messi ma salto fantastico ragazzi ok
luca andato provo io provo io e te nord
man
andiamo con nonno ciak ho paura di cosa
fa quello fratello mirò che cosa è
successo perché ti sei dato all'alcol è
da meno un goccio però madonna mia se
buona sta roba la mia bottiglia la mia
bottiglia la mia bottiglia hai capito
che queste mi atto devi mettere in testa
ragazzi che cazzo ho perso la bottiglia
[ __ ]
non è che per caso c'è una bottiglia da
bere vero quella è la mia bottiglia o
all'ubs bronzo di merda e mia allora
moglie ti porta a far la spesa ok
che cosa vi significa che devo comprare
io dello store di ragazzi doveva
rimanere viva mi dispiace ma non è una
scusa non è una [ __ ] scusa adesso ti
fa il giro to del supermercato mica io
assassins che devo uccidere posso
chiederti gentilmente perché mi stai
mostrando i due gioielli di famiglia
non lo so ma quella che pezzo di merda
alla strada un attimo va uk salvami top
gioca travaglio che finalmente serve a
qualcosa finalmente le figlie a tutte le
loro nicchia se le prese su torino all
ok questo nome la sorpresa gli effettiva
meno al giorno signora le dispiace sara
palco un po ragazzi è una cosa
allucinante ho vinto ho vinto ho vinto
dei palloni in poche parole ma io devo
beccare casa a devo fare canestro ma che
cazzo di me lo devo uscire vinchio se
vive il nostro canestro semi mica se
veniva suo canestro saltava fuori dalla
finestra cazzo vai così ma è così vai
così vai così si no che cazzo fa ma
cos'è
ho vinto ragazzi tranquilli che se la
faccio prima o poi a portare ok mai più
una cosa così a cosa che non ho capito
dammi la birra per fa vj c'è un livello
per me nella classifica mia moglie
da qui per pezzo ciao amore lo so che mi
ami profondamente anche io perdo la
testa per te non in questo senso cazzo
toilette race mai così vorrei a questo
volevo fare mai su vai su vinco io vinco
io
cazzo parlava affanculo che schifo di
motore già successo venite qui luridi
fermi fermi è il mio accesso questo
togliti togliti nonno via di qui ok non
si può fare perché sono tutti i gelosi
del proprio cesso allora vaffan cuore
bar e slow mo kombat
non mi piace come tagliato la barba sai
cosa vuol dire che tela taglio yo yo yo
ma ammettete che adesso sta meglio però
è più sexy
ancora non ho capito perché il quiz per
fa vigente ma quanti livelli mi e ci
sono nella classifica raga sono troppi
gli s grande fa visse unite ti adoro va
bene quanti anni apoli jazz ok meno male
che ho azzeccato perché non avevo
neanche letto e ci devo ragionare su ste
cose perché non lo so lo speciale 10.000
iscritti riguardava momenti epici dei
videogames
il giorno che andata di culo perché non
me lo ricordavo manco io ma non importa
andiamo avanti che fa vi quanti sonic at
mario che fa vige ha giocato quattro
mani no no 5 perché c'è anche katy mario
3d okaka da un attimo bravo ti si è
ricordato di mare certo come posso
dimenticarmi di quella merda ragazzi è
troppo bravo
sono troppo fottutamente per uno
speciale 75mila iscritti riguardava non
mi ricordo se credo la mia ragazza a
ragazza e video gettato è sempre una
prima la risposta ragazza cioè non è
così difficile
super mathc josè starò dalle volte volta
6 mal di testa c'è il momento cento per
cento il prossimo per famiglia è
riuscire a fare questo livello
io non credo ragazzi la mi fate sempre
più ridere perché siete veramente
convinti che riesco a fare la roba ok
questa era di allenamento ragazzi
aspettare nati cos'è sta roba ragazzi
madonna che genio grande vai così vai
così con le capriole vasca [ __ ] stavo
facendo una cosa epica coraggio sim non
è così difficile forza forza impegno a
tutela e la cosa che ci ospita e che le
frecce in faccia non mi fanno nulla anzi
credo cazzo dopo due ore
grandissima l'importante riuscirci
ragazzi direi di concludere qui vino
scusate io cioè di poi inizia la garmin
di brutto quindi è meglio meglio
chiuderla qui comunque vi voglio
ringraziare per essere finiti con tre
livelli nella classifica di è più visti
della settimana siete fantastici ragazzi
se video è piaciuto come al solito show
conto momento mi piace anche la pagina
di facebook e come non i video trovate
nella descrizione sera cena con istinti
scrivete voi ci vediamo al prossimo
video bei ragazzi